seattle's black female police chief
quits as the city council cuts her
salary
america looks for a new normal as the
media continue pushing covid panic
and joe biden makes final vp
preparations i'm bishop and this is
bishop in the his house
today's ben shapiro show bishop in the
hizzy is sponsored by expressvpn your
online activity
shouldn't be public protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
ben alrighty so there's actual news
happening
as the world turns and things actually
happen and people
discover that occasionally i read rap
lyrics on this show
well i mean people find things out on
the internet all the time don't they
you know like several years late so in
any case our cities are burning so
there's that the cities continue to burn
but the good news
is that all the good white liberals over
in seattle have now
basically forced the resignation of the
black
female seattle police chief which makes
perfect sense
because she was really bad at her job in
that she actually wanted to police crime
and the people of seattle don't want her
to police crime or at least the city
council does not want her to police
crime
and so they've now forced her
resignation her name is carmen best
and she has spent an awful lot of time
pointing out that the
that the seattle city council has
basically allowed crime to run roughshod
through the city that they allowed the
setting up of an alternative republic
chess shop
in the middle of seattle now she is out
so the good white folks the good white
woke liberals have decided that in the
name of racial justice the black female
police chief of seattle had to go we'll
get to that in just one second first
with everything going on right now a lot
of people are asking if it's even
possible to buy life insurance
at all the answer of course is yes it is
still easy to shop for life insurance
right now
if you have loved ones depending on your
income you probably should it is the
responsible thing to do right now you
could say 1500
or more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies when you
are shopping for a policy that could
last for a decade or more those savings
really do start to add up what is policy
genius well it's an insurance
marketplace built and backed by a team
of industry experts here's how it works
step one you head on over to
policygenius.com in minutes
you can work out how much coverage you
need and then you compare quotes from
the top insurers and you find your best
price step two you apply for the lowest
price step three
policy genius does the entire rest of it
like soup to nuts the whole thing
they even have policies that allow
eligible customers to skip the in-person
medical exam
and do it over the phone that kind of
service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating across over 1600
reviews on trustpilot and google so
if you need life insurance and you don't
want to get the kind that your friend
just told you about you actually want to
go competitively shop and get the best
kind
go to policygenius.com right now to get
started it could save 1500 bucks or more
a year by comparing quotes on their
marketplace policy genius when it comes
to insurance it is nice to get it right
go check them out right now
policygenius.com
so as i mentioned the seattle police
chief carmen best has now stepped down
according to the
q13fox.com at seattle fox seattle police
chief carmen best is going to resign
two sources familiar with her decision
confirmed to brandy cruz of q13
the decision comes after the seattle
city council voted to slash the
department's budget and
voted to slash her particular salary by
like a hundred
thousand dollars so it's great the the
white person who occupied
her position before was being paid a
hundred thousand dollars more they had
to make sure the black lady
got her salary cut by a hundred thousand
dollars so a bunch of woke white people
could run roughshod through the city and
or
a racialized army could take over the
middle of seattle for two months on end
and then shoot people and prevent the
police from getting in so well done
everybody in seattle the council on
monday approved proposals that would
reduce the police department by up to
100 officers through layoffs and
attrition
chief best was vocal in her opposition
to the cuts budget cuts approved by the
council will eliminate
nearly four million dollars of the
department's 400 million annual budget
while the cuts fell well short of what
black lives matter protesters were
demanding
council members pledged further cuts in
a call to chief bastard went to
unanswered on monday night and mayor
jenny jerkin's office did not
immediately respond to a call
seeking comment she was the first black
woman to lead the spd
she said about the proposal to cut her
pay by 40 quote i do feel like it's an
animus toward me
specifically she's well respected by the
rank and file inside
the department i remember when she was
hired and there was controversy over
whether she was going to
be soft on crime and she obviously was
not because nobody in seattle is soft on
crime enough
nobody in seattle is soft on crime
enough carmen best certainly was not and
so carmen best
has to go and then it's amazing
the media wonder why in the world is
crime spiking all over the united states
why is crime spiking all over the united
states well i have a couple of ideas of
why crime is spiking all over the united
states so do the folks over the daily
caller
peter hassan who writes for the daily
caller has a good report today
talking about how left-wing prosecutors
are basically letting criminals off the
hook
in major cities around the united states
according to the daily caller news
foundation
left-wing prosecutors have implemented
soft-on-crime approaches to criminal
justice across america
in some instances making it a matter of
policy in major cities not to prosecute
specific crimes
a common though not universal feature of
prominent left-wing district attorneys
is the backing of political
organizations funded by funded by george
soros
and let me know the criticism of george
soros here is not because he is jewish
the criticism is because
he is awful in the organizations he
chooses to fund in the united states
he's just as up for that criticism as
anybody else
cook county illinois state attorney
kimberly fox whose jurisdiction includes
chicago
took office in 2017 after winning her
election with the help of a soros funded
super pac
soros poured more than 400 thousand
dollars into illinois justice and public
safety pack in 2016
illinois state board of election records
show she was the only candidate fox the
pac supported in 2016.
she announced in december 2016 that her
office would not charge shoplifters with
felonies
unless they either had more than 10
previous felony convictions 10
previous felony convictions or if they
stole more than a thousand dollars
worth of goods the previous lower level
was 300
store owners blamed fox's policies in
december 2019 for what they said was a
string of brazen thefts targeting their
businesses and then
fox announced in june she wouldn't
prosecute protesters charged with minor
crimes like curfew violations and
disorderly conduct
multiple analyses of fox's record have
shown have found significant decreases
in prosecutions
since she took office the chicago
tribune on monday reported that fox
dropped all charges against 30
of all defendants in her first three
years in office
her predecessor a woman named danita
alvarez who was a democrat and also soft
on crime dropped charges against 20
of defendants in her final three years
on the job
a separate study from the marshall
project and nonprofit supporting
criminal justice reform
found fox dropped thousands of cases
that would have been prosecuted by
her predecessors not just her suffolk
county massachusetts district attorney
rachel rollins whose jurisdiction
includes boston
campaigned in 2018 on a list of 15
crimes her office would not prosecute as
a matter of policy including
trespassing wanton or malicious
destruction of property shoplifting and
larceny under 250
the boston herald reported in may 2019
an attempted shoplifter was shocked when
he was arrested for allegedly pilfering
more than a hundred dollars worth of
goods from the local store he didn't
realize that he was outside
rollins jurisdiction he said he he knew
that he wouldn't be prosecuted thanks to
rollins policies but
unfortunately he was in the neighboring
city
it's not just rollins either
philadelphia district attorney larry
krasner is a former defense attorney who
had never prosecuted a case before
becoming philadelphia's top prosecutor
george soros put 1.45 million dollars
into a back
super pac backing krasner in the
democratic primary in may 2017.
he said in an nbc news podcast interview
last month law enforcement agencies
point to repeat offenders as evidence of
the need for harsher sentences but
he says that he rejects that view quote
they'll list all of the arrests they've
had all the contacts they've had is if
what they are doing is explaining that
these people
are of terrible character and that
explains this phenomenon what they're
not saying is the system
has engaged this person arrested this
person 15 times convicted them seven
times put them in jail four times and
nothing worked it all failed
they're not owning that so in other
words when a person is a repeat criminal
to the tune of dozens of crimes then
that's not because the person's a bad
person it's because the system is a bad
system
which is totally wild and is it any
shock that homicides this year
in philadelphia are up 30 compared to
the same time period
last year it should not be in san
francisco district attorney chase
abaddon
pledged during his campaign that certain
quality of life crimes including public
urination
would not be prosecuted by his office so
people peeing freely and
and doing heroin on the streets of san
francisco it's all great
bowden said in a july 29th in a 2019
interview that he would challenge
the legitimacy of laws by not bringing
certain charges
he said the types of charges a d.a
declines it to bring has a ripple effect
and changes the culture of a community
setting prostitution as an example
of a crime he would not prosecute he
said he would not prosecute contraband
charges that originated as minor traffic
infractions
also he stopped using gang affiliation
status in sentencing enhancement so it
makes it easier
for gangs really solid stuff at major
cities across
the united states and then we wonder why
why in the world is crime increasing
across the board why we're getting rid
of the cops and meanwhile we have da's
who are pledging openly that they want
to allow criminals to run roughshod
through cities
i mean why it's just it's also puzzling
it's super duper puzzling the new york
times in fact had a headline yesterday
wondering openly what could have created
this violence in chicago i mean it's
just
it's so confusing it's a mystery wrapped
in an enigma
i mean it's wow we we need sherlock
holmes on this one
according to the new york times chicago
police arrested more than 100 people
after looting batters downtown
this was just yesterday all summer
demonstrators have marched through
chicago to protest police misconduct
reported the new york times
in many neighborhoods gun violence has
been unrelenting soaring to levels not
seen in decades
the coronavirus pandemic is resurging
now sickening hundreds of people
a day then early monday morning hundreds
of people spurred by a police shooting
and by calls on social media to take
action in the gleaming heart of the city
converged
on magnificent mile chicago's most
famous shopping district
they broke windows looted stores and
clashed with the police a chaotic and
confusing scene
that prompted city officials to briefly
raise bridges downtown and halt nearby
public transit to stem the unrest
two people were shot at least 13 police
officers were injured apparently people
were literally
on the upper levels of buildings and
they were throwing planters
down on the heads of cops in chicago
okay which is assault with a deadly
weapon
the events instantly played into a
broader political dynamic of the season
in which president trump has regularly
portrayed chicago as a poorly governed
hotbed
of violent crime it's about how trump
portrayed it it's not that it's a poorly
government hop in a violent crime it's
that trump keeps portraying it that way
that's the real issue here
republicans pounce lots of pouncing
mayor lori lightfoot a democrat
expressed
fury over the violence and ordered
limited access to downtown starting on
monday evening apparently they shut down
miracle they shut down magnificent mile
between like 8 p.m and 6 a.m which is
really good for business
obviously lightfoot still said we don't
need federal troops in chicago period
full stop everything is
is is still everything's still okay she
said at a news conference we're waking
up in shock this morning what occurred
downtown and in surrounding communities
was abject criminal behavior
pure and simple oh was it oh was it but
when mayor lori lightfoot was asked
for example like maybe it's because you
guys refused to actually stop
crime that crime is rising in her city
she's like stop baiting us stop baiting
us media
stop that it almost sounds as though
you're saying this is
the reason we happened is because the
courts and the prosecutors were not
doing
their job that they were going too easy
on the looters from the last time around
him
don't take it from me let's be clear
don't bait us
okay this is
this is a serious situation people are
concerned about their safety
i love that the police superintendent
was about to step in and be like yes
that's exactly what we're saying we're
saying that you guys keep letting
criminals out of jail
and that we are being hamstrung from
doing our job and then lori lightfoot is
like
stop baiting us stop it you're gonna
need to stop baiting us right now that's
not baiting that's an honest question
by the way aren't those attacks on a
free press every time trump gets a
little bit mad at the media
every time he gets a little uppity with
the media trump then everybody's like
wow that's an attack on a free press
laurie lightfoot there she stopped
baiting us when somebody asks her a
perfectly legit question about her own
garbage policies
and i was like well you know that's lori
lifeless slay queen slay
we'll get to more of this in a second
but by the way the chicago police
superintendent for his part
he was asked about this he said this is
pure criminality this has nothing to do
with social justice
so we'll get to that in here he was here
was yesterday
400 officers were dispatched to our
downtown
as the officers arrived to our downtown
the first incident happened at a store
near the 87th and the dan ryan
expressway
soon car caravans were headed into the
loop
this was not an organized protest rather
this was an incident of
pure criminality this was an
act of violence against our police
officers and against our city
but don't worry if we ask why that
happened that's the problem as we'll see
from the new york times people are
puzzled puzzled
how could any of this have happened in
america's major cities i mean it's like
when you remove the cops and you tell
the criminals they can have free reign
over the city
bad things happen but it's a mystery no
one understands guys
and if you say you understand this
because you're baiting people we'll get
to that in just one second first
it is time to point out that you need a
nice watch
okay when we finally emerge from all of
this there is going to be a moment where
people go out
and they're having fun they're going to
parties and you want to have a nice
watch i am a timepiece guy i love
nice watches but i understand that not
everybody can afford like a 5 000
rolex right some people just want a nice
watch at a really good price
this is why i really enjoy my vincero
check out this vincero
watch right here gotta it's actually so
thick that i have to
unleash the uh the sleeve right here if
i can get it out from underneath
here we go look at this ventura watch
this is really pretty this is a very
very pretty watch
this is a chronograph from vincero it's
really really nice
check this out here it is yeah really
nice why do i love interior i'll tell
you why i love intro first the price
point is fantastic
pretty much anybody can afford what
looks like a luxury watch for a
non-luxury price it is fantastic
these are watches that are stunning and
well under two hundred dollars
and they really do stand out when i wear
ventura watch people ask me
what kind of watch it is because it is
such a good looking watch right now
vincero is running a site-wide sale to
celebrate their sixth anniversary
this will be the biggest sale in vincero
history up to 30
off site-wide no code required your
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout when you visit
vincerowatches.com shapiro that's
v-i-n-c-e-r-o-watches dot com slash
apparel venturawatches.com
shapiro everything on site is on sale no
exclusions this includes all four of
their new
collections all of them are available
they're shipping all orders directly
from their local us distributors they're
delivering all orders on time no delays
they want you to get your product to you
as quickly as possible
there's no brand name markup by the way
so much of luxury watch selling is about
the brand name markup
no big-time price tags that promise you
is very simple solid well-made
well-made products that are durable
you'll enjoy wearing them and they're
gonna look really great
ventura offers free shipping 30-day
returns guarantees your watch for two
years which is why they have over
twenty two thousand five star reviews i
mean look at this thing it's beautiful
i mean it's shiny it is well crafted and
again i look for durability and watches
i have little kids i only buy watches
that are durable
vincero these are durable watches
continue to support this brand as they
continue to support
the ben shapiro show go to shop
vincero's sixth anniversary sale the
deal really is too good to pass up go to
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com
forward slash shapiro don't pay full
prices on these beautiful timepieces
instead
go get a great venture watch right now
take advantage of the opportunity get
one of my go-to watches at a fantastic
price right now right now again you go
to venturawatches.com
shapiro and you're going to get 30 up up
to 30
off site y which is a fantastic
fantastic deal okay so the new york
times is absolutely puzzled
as to how this could have happened in
new york listen listen to the way this
is covered
quote i mean in chicago quote the event
left
chicagoans shaken and wondering what had
sparked the burst of vandalism that
destroyed storefronts and littered
sidewalks with debris
on one of the most recognizable avenues
in the city since spring downtown
chicago has often had a quiet eerie feel
without the hordes of tourists and
commuters that usually fill the
sidewalks theaters restaurants and bars
office vacancies remain high because of
fears over covet and previous bouts of
civil unrest earlier this summer have
also kept crowds low
reverend corey brooks a pastor on
chicago's south side said these last few
months have been tremendously difficult
for a lot of people
people are hurting financially
emotionally psychologically there's a
lot of suffering going on what happened
last night sets us back
even more it's so confusing it's so
confu what could have happened in the
light of day there were many questions
over whether the violence had resulted
because of differing versions of what
had happened
in this police shooting okay here's what
happened there's a 20-year-old guy in an
alley there's a report that he was
running around the gun the cops arrived
he tried to shoot them and then they
shot him okay that's what happened
quickly rumors started going around that
they had shot a 15 year old who was
unarmed
and then people were like you know what
great opportunity to go smash and grab
some stuff
over in the middle of chicago loop
but it's so mysterious so mysterious how
could this have all happened i mean
aside from a media
that will immediately jump on any story
of a
black person being shot by the police
and not wait for any of the details to
come out
and a political class that will repeat
lies about situations like that i mean
joe biden yesterday was literally
retweeting lies about
michael brown's death in st louis okay
michael brown it's been found by
multiple different investigations
including the obama doj
attacked a police officer and then tried
to attack a police officer again before
he was shot
okay and still a democratic factom has
become this idea
that michael brown was an innocent who
was shot in cold blood with his hands up
okay it is which is not true so the
combination of a media that is deeply
irresponsible on racial issues and
deeply irresponsible
on the shootings that police sometimes
are forced to do
and a democratic party infrastructure
that repeats open lies
about what happens under many
circumstances
that combination combined with again a
deeply irresponsible media that pretends
that rioting and looting are a
legitimate form of protest
and a democratic party that is willing
to allow criminality to go unchecked
i i can't imagine how that heady brew
resulted in a rise in crime that is
devastating cities across
the country detroit's police chief by
the way is saying the same thing
so crime is up in detroit which again
crime being up in detroit
is is like saying that the sun rises in
the morning
and crime is always up in detroit so the
fact that it's up even more in detroit
is is disquieting
so detroit's police chief guy named
james craig he said you know what's been
happening here these false narratives
perpetuated by criminals and then
repeated by the media which of course is
right
one of the things that we saw here in
detroit almost eerily similar to what
happened last night in chicago
a false narrative was perpetrated by
these criminals very quickly
and indicated that a unarmed teen was
shot
and then called for people to come
downtown loot
the one similarity is that the criminals
try to do the same thing here in detroit
about three weeks ago
when our officers were fired upon and we
ended up using deadly force
they put out a false narrative that we
shot an unarmed
african-american man seated on his porch
totally
false okay and what if the media does
debunk these things nothing
all they do is they just light a fire
under all of this and then if you say
you know what we need more cops we need
to stop the crime
then you're the bad guy now here's the
thing it's not just conservative people
saying this
as it turns out there are lots of people
who live in these cities who would like
to see more cops
in fact 81 according to a recent gallup
of black americans say they want to see
at least the same level of policing or
more policing in their communities
that is not the narrative you'll hear
from the media that's not the narrative
you're going to hear from democrats
that's why you get all these white woke
idiots in seattle
basically forcing the black female
police chief
out of her job in seattle worth noting
then a huge number of america's major
cities
if not a majority a very large minority
of the police forces itself minority in
los angeles where the police are
constantly criticized a majority of the
police forces minority
in washington dc a majority of the
police force is minority
in new york city about 50 percent of the
in chicago about 50 of the police force
minority like what
what are you talking about here like the
cops are systemically racist and we
remove the cops and the criminals should
be allowed free reign and then the crime
rates go up and everybody's like mystery
mystery how could it have happened the
only people who don't like this stuff
are the people who actually have to live
in these cities at a certain point
they're gonna have to stop voting for
for damned morons
if they want to have their city back
because otherwise as i
i'm more and more frequently quoting h.l
menken here the american people
get what they deserve good and hard if
you keep voting for the same politicians
who do this kind of crap then you
shouldn't be surprised when they are
breaking into the nicest areas of your
city
and smashing and grabbing things and
shooting people in the worst parts of
the city
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about how
hiring can be kind of complicated these
days if you're looking for a job it's a
pretty
rough job market that means that you
need to be notified of a job that you
are eligible for like asap and if you're
an employer
you need to know about the best possible
employees this is why you need zip
recruiter zip recruiter we'll send your
job to over 100 of the web's leading
job sites but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter will scan thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and then actively invite them
to apply
to your job zip recruiter makes the
entire hiring process efficient and
effective
with features like screening questions
to filter candidates and all-in-one
dashboards where you can review and rate
your candidate
in fact ziprecruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day all of my employees
feel the threat all of my employees know
that if they don't do their job and one
day they could find themselves
out and we could be looking on zip
recruiter for their replacement i mean
if we had an employee named nick who
just
every morning just brought in memes of
me rapping he could find himself very
quickly zip recruiter
right now to try zip recruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
zip recruiter dot com slash daily wire
zip recorder is indeed the smartest way
to hire go check them out
right now ziprecruiter.com dailywire
okay so it turns out that it is not
merely conservatives who are upset about
you know the rising crime in the cities
it turns out that there are a lot of
black lawmakers who are not
particularly fond of the idea that the
cops are the problem
according to the new york times with new
york city on the cusp of cutting one
billion dollars from the police
department
a city councilwoman vanessa gibson told
her colleagues enough was enough
she acknowledged some council members
spurred by the movement to defund police
or seeking to slash even more from the
department's budget
but she pointed out her constituents did
not agree they want to see cops in the
community said miss gibson by the way
why did they take the new york times
months to report on this
months why was it that for months it was
the cops were the bad guys
and then oh you know maybe we ought to
ask some you know actual black people
living in
heavily crime-ridden areas like what
they think about the cops maybe maybe we
ought to like
survey that as opposed to surveying the
heavily white population of the new york
times editorial board
maybe we should stop asking paul krugman
about policing in the inner cities and
maybe we should start asking
you know the impoverished person living
in a crime-ridden area who just wants a
job
and to raise their children in safety
well done mainstream media
well done ms gibson said
they want to see cops in the community
they don't want to see excessive force
but they want to be safe as they go to
the store
ms gibson is not a conservative
politician speaking on behalf of an
affluent district she's a liberal black
democrat who represents the west bronx
her stance reflects a growing
ideological rift over policing
in one of the country's liberal bastions
it is a clash across racial ideological
and generational lines that is dividing
black and latino council members in new
york city
the discord illustrates how complicated
the nation's struggle with his legacy of
racial oppression and discriminatory
policing has become
no what it really reflects is the fact
that the media refused to cover the fact
that cops generally do a very very good
job and keep people safe
which is why again it is an eight to two
proposition in the black community
same number of police or more that is an
80 20 proposition now if
you just watch the media coverage over
the past few months you think it's an 80
20 proposition the other way
that black americans are desperate to
get the cops out that is not correct
it has not been correct for decades okay
what might have been justifiable in a
time when the cops were literally an
instrument
of racial oppression particularly in the
jim crow south it has not been true
for decades in the united states when
the chief methodology
of relieving poverty is ensuring that
people can go to work without their
store being robbed that their kids can
go to school without being shot by a
gang member
lori combo a black councilwoman from
brooklyn who's a majority leader
compared calls to defund the police to
colonization pushed by white
progressives
correct correct it is a bunch of asshat
white woke leftists who are pushing
policies that hurt disproportionately
minority populations
robert carnegie jr a black councilman
called the movement political
gentrification
mayor ross baraka of newark new jersey
called defunding the police a bourgeois
liberal solution for addressing systemic
racism
yeah no no believe sherlock correct
during the debate black and latino
council members representing both poor
and middle-class communities of color
including brownsville brooklyn and
jamaica queens
wanted to take a measured approach to
measured approach to cutting the police
budget
white progressives allied with some
latino council members from gentrifying
and racially mixed neighborhoods and two
black council members called for more
aggressive reductions and reforms
of course of course they did so the
people who are least affected
by bad policy are the ones who are
calling for the greatest change
who could have predicted such a thing we
definitely need to hear from upper class
communist mayor bill de blasio talking
about the needs
of of lower income black americans
living in high crime gang infested areas
clearly we need to hear from bill de
blasio we must
we need to hear from the all-white team
over at the nation on this
when can we hear from the daily coast
very very important stuff
by 32 to 17 votes the council with mr
bill de blasio's support eventually
passed an 88.2 billion dollar budget
that included a reduction in police
funding
the one billion dollar cut was mostly
cosmetic moving responsibilities from
the pd to other agencies the size of the
force will barely change says the new
york times nearly all the no votes were
cast by white conservatives
opposed to reductions or white and
latino council members who wanted deeper
cuts
corey johnson council speaker said he
would have preferred to cut more but he
wanted to defer to his black and latino
colleagues who raised concerns about the
safety
of their neighborhoods well if you
wanted to defer to them why wouldn't you
increase the funding for cops that's
what you need
how it became uh honestly how it became
a controversial proposition that high
crime areas require more police officers
it's dear election of media duty but
that is what we've been watching because
the narrative matters
far far more than the reality of people
living lives
in health and happiness guaranteed the
pursuit of life liberty and happiness
it remains an absolutely incredible feat
that boggles the imagination
that so many white woke leftists have
been able to completely ignore the
actual needs that every american citizen
deserves for law order
it isn't one order is not a racist
slogan one order is the way that you
prevent predation
get predation against all americans in
just a second
we're gonna get to bizarre news from
russia russia is now saying that they
have a vaccine
for covet suffice it to say that uh i
have doubts
i have some doubts we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about a great gift something
great that you can get for your parents
no i'm not talking about the latest
cardi b
album i'm talking about something
fantastic you can do for your family
right remember family family is great
i'm talking about legacy box it's a
super simple mail-in service to have all
your videotapes
camcorder tapes film reels pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive
dvd or the cloud are your family's
memories trapped on an old camcorder
or film reels right when's the last time
that you popped out a camcorder cassette
you put it in one of those old vhs
things and then you put in a vcr you
don't own any of those things anymore
instead you need all the stuff digitized
so you can watch it as you can relive it
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past
in fact my parents right now are going
through their garage they came across a
bunch of boxes of stuff
i immediately went to legacy box i got
them a bevy of boxes so they can have
all of that stuff preserved for
themselves and for future
generations get started future proofing
your memories today so you can gather
the family and begin the trip down
memory lane go to legacybox.com get an
incredible 40
off your first order you can buy today
and then doesn't matter if it takes you
a few weeks to collect all this stuff
you send it in when you're ready go to
legacybox.com
shapiro save 40 while supplies last
again really meaningful gift something
deeply important legacybox.com
slash apparel get an incredible 40 off
your first order while supplies last go
check them out
right now okay meanwhile in covet land
russia now says that they have approved
a coronavirus vaccine
for use in tens of thousands of its
citizens despite international
skepticism about injections that have
not completed clinical trials and were
studied in only dozens of people for
less than two months according to the ap
now russia has sort of a national
interest in
presenting itself as the leader on the
on the bleeding edge of fighting
kovid vladimir putin in unsurprising
fashion announced that he'd injected his
own daughter with this thing which
given the history of russian leaders and
their treatment of their own children is
not
supremely surprising putin said while
announcing the approval one of his two
adult daughters was already inoculated
he said the vaccine underwent the
necessary tests and was shown to provide
lasting immunity to covid
russian authorities have to this point
offered zero proof to back up their
claims of safety or effectiveness
he says i know it is proven efficient
and forms a stable immunity
scientists in russia and other countries
sounded an alarm they said um you
haven't even had like a phase three
trial yet
right there's phase one is like you
develop a vaccine phase three is where
you have widespread human trials
they haven't even done that like at all
fast-tracked approval will not make
russia the leader in the vaccine race it
will just expose consumers of the
vaccine to unnecessary danger
said russia's association of clinical
trials organization they urged the
government to postpone clearing the
vaccine without completing
advanced trials the vaccine developed by
the gamalaya institute in moscow uses a
different virus the common cold
causing adenovirus that's been modified
to carry genes for the spike protein
that coats the coronavirus
as a way to prime the body to recognize
if a real covenant 19 infection comes
along that is similar to the vaccines
being developed by oxford university
and astrazeneca well we're going to find
out in pretty short order whether this
thing works or whether russia is just
rushing out an untested vaccine
in order to quote unquote win the race
russia apparently is going to inject all
its healthcare workers with this thing
so that's a little scary another reason
why
russia is not in fact a wonderful place
to live meanwhile
there's some serious talk now about you
know how we actually live
with this thing how we live with it
because the reality is that even when a
vaccine is developed you don't know it
will be 100 effective
we don't know how many people will take
it we don't know how long it will be
effective for
there's still lots of questions here now
people are upbeat about the possibility
of a vaccine
the goldman sachs was suggesting
yesterday that the vaccine would be
developed by q2 of 2021. well last i
checked the calendar
it is only q3 right now of 2020. so that
is a
long time when we're all supposed to
basically what hide in our houses and
cower in silence
and that's really silly i've been
pointing out for months
months months at this point that there
is a vast difference between if you are
20 and you get covered and you are 80
and you get covered you get 80 you're 80
and you get coven
solid chance it kills you if you're 20
and you get covered you ain't dying from
it statistically speaking
the number of people who have died from
covid at age 20
is my newt it is my nude in fact if you
compare
the the chances of death at age 80
from covid to the chances of death for
each prior
20 years just cut it by about
10 times so you are 10 times less likely
to die of covet if you are 60 than if
you are 80
you're 100 times less likely to die of
covet if you are 40 than if you are 80
and you are 1 000 times
less likely to die of covet if you are
20 than if you are 80.
which is to say if you're 20 you're not
statistically speaking you're not dying
of covet
like there are rare occasions in which
people will die of covet at the age of
20 to pretend that this
acts as some sort of rationale for
shutting down society for 20 year olds
is utterly not it's utterly not
and we should also be very skeptical of
people who suggest that when a 20 year
old gets coveted and then doesn't die of
covet and is basically fine of covered
something terrible has happened
when a young person obtains covid and
doesn't infect somebody old something
good has happened
the person is now presumably immune to
kovid
which means they cannot pass it okay so
the the media have been treating it as
though each additional diagnosed case is
in and of itself a disaster
if a 15 year old is diagnosed with
covenant and doesn't infect somebody
who's vulnerable
and then has a cold for a week that is
not only not the end of the world
something good has happened we have
moved toward herd immunity
i know we're not supposed to talk about
herd immunity but there's some pretty
good evidence that um herd immunity has
already been reached
in sweden for example there there's a
there's a
pretty good there's there's pretty good
evidence that sweden
got it right okay so the death numbers
in sweden are not good the reason the
death numbers in sweden are not good is
because they didn't protect their
nursing homes properly at the very
beginning
but if you look at their day on day
cases and their day on day deaths at
this point and they never shut down
then what you see is that sweden is
actually
now in great shape sweden is now in
excellent shape and as i say they have
now been dropping
fairly precipitously in the rankings of
death per million population
so bel sweden started up like near the
top of the list sweden is now down to
number eight
they rank just above chile and the
united states
they have 571 deaths per million but
they're stagnant which means they're
going to stay there
now brazil will surpass them the united
states will probably surpass them at
some point
france i think will probably surpass
them i think mexico will probably
surpass them
the netherlands may surpass them
depending on how this thing washes
through the population bottom line is
the evidence from pretty much everywhere
is that what happens this thing washes
through the population you either
protect those who are vulnerable or you
do not
and that's pretty much the only choice
you have right now if you look at the
daily new cases in sweden
they've been stagnant daily new cases
yesterday in sweden 139
139 cases in sweden daily new deaths in
sweden i'm going to redo for the last
couple of weeks
one two three one
zero one one two okay so
sweden's curve looks exactly like you
would expect when you reach hurt
immunity
because they didn't shut down and guess
what masquerading in sweden is actually
not much of a thing
they've been doing some social
distancing not a lot of mass squaring
it's below 10
of the population wears a mask this is
not a case that you shouldn't wear a
mask when you're in a public area
a crowded area of sweden has a much
healthier population and a younger
population
than the united states typically
speaking the rule about masks is that it
is meant basically to protect other
people
from your disease so if you have covid
you're protecting somebody who is 60 and
obese or you're protecting grandma from
it and that's a good thing
that's a good thing you want to slow the
spread but the notion that we have to
prevent 20 year olds from going to
parties
or that 20 year olds partying like we
saw over the weekend lori lightfoot
getting very mad there was some sort of
lgbt party in which there were a bunch
of people out at a park and she like
shut it down and she was tweeting out
about how terrible this was meanwhile
the chicago loop was getting completely
ransacked nothing
horrifying was happening there nothing
horrifying was happening there if
there's a block party with a bunch of 20
year olds who then don't go home and
infect their families
it ain't bad it isn't it's like honestly
colleges should be open right now
colleges should be open and if 20 year
olds want to slow this bread
they should slow this bread and if they
get it they're going to be mostly fine
and that is not the end of the world
it is not the end of the world dr
anthony fauci even is saying listen the
virus is not disappearing
he says we should wear masks to reopen
the schools mainly because we are
concerned about kids going home and
infecting their parents but if a 15 year
old gets coveted it is not only not the
end of the world it is not particularly
dangerous by any stretch of the
imagination
we have not seen any systemic evidence
that suggests that 15 year olds are a
dire threat
15 year olds are significantly more
likely to die of the flu than they are
to die of cobalt
here is anthony fauci yesterday are you
comfortable with those words this is
disappearing
well there would have to be in addition
to that we could get it to be under
control
if we do the things that we're talking
about but at 50 60
70 000 cases a day it's not disappearing
at the moment
no it's not should all students in this
country be wearing masks
you know i'm one and i've said it for so
so long david
that i really do believe if you if and
and it's part of
what i call a comprehensive way to
really avoid the things that you were
just referring to
there should be universal wearing of
masks okay so he says there should be
universal mask wearing okay well here's
vanit menchari corona virus researcher
at the university of texas medical
branch
told npr's weekend edition that it is
unlikely that vaccine is going to be the
end of the
is going to be the end of this thing he
says in fact there's a good chance that
covet 19 never fully goes away with or
without a vaccine
what does he say he says that the spread
of coca-19 will eventually be slowed as
a result of herd immunity
is to npr's weekend edition he said he'd
be surprised if we're still wearing
masks
and six feet distancing in two or three
years he said in that time the virus
will become no more serious
than could become no more serious than
the common cold
why almost as though everything that we
have been saying here on the
anti-lockdown
right is basically correct meanwhile the
media
continue to cover for andrew cuomo by
the way we'll get to that in a second
we'll get to that in just a moment okay
there are new reports out that andrew
cuomo basically hit thousands of coveted
deaths in nursing homes
which is we got to get chris on this
right away when he's not reporting on
giant nasal swabs for his bro
then we got it we got to get chris on
this right away by the way what this
doctor says
he says the expectation i have is the
virus will actually become the next
common cold
well we don't know what these common
cold coronaviruses is if they went
through a similar transition period
he says it's been historically reported
there's an outbreak associated
for the transition from something like
oc-43 that is the common cold
coronavirus he said there was something
there's an outbreak associated with the
transition of that virus from cows to
humans it was very severe and then after
a few years the virus became
the common cold he said in three to five
years and maybe you're still getting
covet 19 in certain populations of
people or every few years
the expectation is hopefully it'll
become the common cold
okay and that'll happen through probably
something resembling natural herd
immunity
so in a second we're going to get to the
big ten so the big ten is now
talking about shutting down the college
football season 20 year olds getting
coconut
the healthiest 20 year olds in america
right they're playing football
getting coveted 19 is not a threat to
them and it's not a threat to the
country
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact it is deeply important for you
to protect your online data there are
people who want to blackmail you with
your online data there are people who
want to hack into your online data and
then just steal your credit card number
this is why you need pcmatic pcmatic is
a next generation antivirus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware independent testing from a v
test
just named pcmatic as a top performer in
the cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic blocks annoying malicious ads
for hassle-free web browsing and makes
your computers faster and more reliable
even after years of use
vcmatic protects windows computers
including xp vista
windows 7 8 and 10 windows servers max
macbooks and android phones and tablets
among others pcmatic
is just 50 bucks for five devices for
one year which is a fantastic
deal full 30 day money back guarantee if
you ask right now pcmatic has offered my
listeners a free month of security
protection with the purchase
of an annual license to access this
offer head on over to pcmatic.com
again to get world-class security that
keeps your computers running great
go to pcmatic.com that's pcmatic.com
50 bucks for five devices for one year
30 day money back guarantee you got
nothing to lose and you're going to
protect yourself from
the bad guys online go check them out
right now pcmatic.com
okay in just a second we're going to get
to controversy over whether college
football
should reopen the short answer is
obviously yes but that's not going to
stop everybody from precipitous panic
precipitous panic
first i need to tell you about our most
exclusive membership tier over at the
daily wire all access
all access members get to join all
access live our exclusive
live stream q a hosted every night by
each of the hosts including me
this thursday august 13th for example
i'll be hosting an all-access live to
discuss my new book how to destroy
america in three easy steps
it has been at the top of the charts
since it was released in mid-july
got a lot of amazing feedback questions
from readers this thursday night i'll be
taking questions
and discussing some of the themes ideas
etc in the book with all of you all
access members i also
sing songs and and do dances and and
apparently recite rap lyrics that might
be a thing who knows so if you really
really enjoyed my rendition of whap
then perhaps you can get other rap songs
read aloud by me
all access membership also features
exclusive access to live online
discussions with our hosts writers and
special guests along
with not one but two leftist tiers
tumblers with your membership as well as
early and sometimes exclusive access to
new daily wire products which you saw
last week that our limited account
collector's edition baseball bat
was available only to all access members
it sold out in less than 48 hours
so you missed your chance but you won't
have to miss your chance with the next
all-access offer
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
you can also get my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps at amazon or barnes noble if you
want to join the discussion remember
dailywire.com shapiro coupon code access
to get 20
off your membership you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so alarmism leads to incredibly stupid
policy the big ten
is now talking about completely
cancelling their football season
according to the detroit free press the
big ten is expected to cancel
its fall college football season in a
historic move that stems from concerns
related to the coveted pandemic it's
done one high-ranking source in the big
ten said monday afternoon
sources said the presidents were in
favor sunday of not playing sports in
the conference this fall
michigan and michigan state which both
have physicians as presidents were among
the schools in favor of not playing
according to sources
multiple sources said early monday
morning presidents voted 12 to 2
to not play this fall but the big 10
said monday afternoon no official vote
had taken place
dan patrick who first reported the 12-2
vote said on his radio show iowa and
nebraska were the two schools in favor
of playing jim harbaugh by the way said
that college football should be played
he says like these are all young healthy
people coaches and players in the
conference including
jim harbaugh ohio state ryan's a
nebraska scott frost osu quarterback
justin fields have lobbied for the
season to commence
day said it's swinging as hard as we
possibly can right now for these players
this isn't over
harbaugh put out hashtags hashtag we
want to play and hashtag we want to
coach
on monday afternoon espn college
football analyst kirk kerbstreet tweeted
to be clear regarding big ten football
and their impending announcement they
are looking to delay the start of the
season
not to cancel the chicago tribune
reported around noon a top-level big ten
source texted no decisions had been made
but
it is pretty obvious that this is the
direction in which they are moving
this is frankly incredibly dumb okay the
the fact is
that a bunch of of 20 year olds playing
football
presumably within some sort of bubble
and if some of them get covered
that is not it's not they're on a campus
okay they're not in contact with their
parents they're not going home
and being with grandma trevor lawrence
the heisman winning
quarterback he put out a tweet
that said hashtag we want to play it
says we want we all want to play
football this season
establish universal mandated health and
safety procedures and protocols to
protect college athletes against cover
among all conferences throughout the
ncaa give players the opportunity to opt
out respect their decision
guarantee eligibility whether a player
chooses to play the season or not
use our voices to establish open
communication and trust between players
and officials
ultimately create a college football
players association representative of
the players of all power five at
conferences
okay all of that is good and president
trump seconded the motion he tweeted
this out
he also tweeted out play college
football and dr scott atlas of stanford
who is an expert he's more of an expert
than members of the media he said
yesterday college
football players are not at a res
they're virtually zero risk this of
course is exactly right
we're talking about people who are
physical specimens who are
really super young people young people
that age
without a comorbidity have virtually
zero risk from this we have to again
become rational here the risk for people
that age is less than
seasonal influenza i mean you have to
really look at the data and you
again you can't say it's all about the
science and then act contrary to science
so this is a perfect situation here uh
but we are going to ignore the science
because we all have to pretend that if a
20 year old gets coveted 19 it is the
worst thing that has ever happened to
that person even though again
the chances of you dying from cover 19
at age 20 are worse than the chance that
they're gonna die of flu
at age 20 meanwhile we are still being
told by the media that andrew cuomo was
a great governor
the gaslighting from the media uncovered
is absolutely insane
insane like totally crazy we now know
according to the ap new york's true
nursing home death toll cloaked in
secrecy
cloaked in secrecy why i was told that
ron
sans is the bad guy in this little
morality play we've been doing and that
andrew cuomo was the good guy remember
he even put together a creepy
paper mache mountain of death and he
stood next to it and then he lectured
people with his wall of masks
it's all something from a horror film
and then he put together a weird poster
with the boyfriend cliff remember that
and that guy was the hero he was the
hero of the story well now it turns out
that probably one third of all the
people who died in new york state
died in nursing homes because this tool
bag decided it was a great idea to ship
people who were coveted positive back
into nursing homes
and then covered up the numbers
according to the ap riverdale nursing
home in the bronx appears on paper to
have escaped the worst of the
coronavirus pandemic with an official
state count of just four deaths in its
146 bed facility
the truth according to the home is far
worse 21 dead
most transported to hospitals before
they succumbed it was a cascading effect
that administrator emil fuzaiov
one after the other new york's
coronavirus death toll in the nursing
homes already among the highest in the
nation could actually be a significant
undercount
unlike every other state with major
outbreaks new york only counts residents
who died on nursing home property
and not those who were transported to
hospitals and died there so if you
called the hospital you're like bring an
ambulance and the person died five
minutes later in the ambulance they
don't count as a nursing home death in
new york because the android cuomo has
to cover up the stats
that statistic could add thousands to
the state's official
care home death toll of just over 6 600.
so far
andrew cuomo has refused to divulge the
number
that's a problem bro state senator
gustavo rivera democrat told new york
health commissioner howard zuckerberg
during the legislative hearing by the
way
cuomo said yesterday we don't need an
independent investigation into my
handling of this
i handled it great i don't think we need
an independent investigation
who could have predicted this from the
world's greatest governor how big a
difference could this make
since may federal regulators have
required nursing homes to submit data on
coronavirus deaths each week
whether or not residents died in the
facility or to hospital because the
requirement came after the height of new
york's outbreak the available data is
relatively small
even if half the undercount held true
from the start of the pandemic that
would translate into thousands
more nursing home resident deaths than
the state has acknowledged
state health department surveys show 21
000 nursing home beds are lying empty
this year
13 000 more than expected that's an
increase of almost double the official
state nursing home death tally
so it could be up to 13 000 people died
in the nursing homes
that has not stopped chris andrew cuomo
from being a damned liar
he said look at the basic facts where
new york is versus other states this is
on a briefing
on monday on monday you look at where
new york is as a percentage of nursing
home deaths
it's all the way at the bottom of the
list yeah when you lie about it that's
what happens
when you lie about it that's what
happens boston university geriatrics
expert thomas pearl said whatever the
whatever the cause there's no way that
new york's nursing home resident deaths
are only 20
of the total deaths that's obviously
untrue
so we've been told ron desantis engaged
in a cover up he did not
their data in florida is much better
than the data in new york we've been
told that andrew cuomo was great at his
job he was not
and then just to make sure that nobody
could actually you know speak openly
about this janet dean
janisteen rather on fox news who does
some of the weather over there
she had a mom who died in a nursing home
facility
in new york and she was going off on
andrew cuomo's handling of the
coronavirus pandemic
she was invited to testify before the
new york state legislature about the
covet handling in new york and then she
was uninvited because they're afraid of
what she might say about the garbage
governor of new york andrew cuomo here
was janisteen
assemblyman kevin byrne uh was the one
that was
you know emailing me back and forth and
saying that he was talking to the chair
and that the chair said absolutely
she'll get her day
on august the 10th today and then i was
supposed to hear something over the
weekend
i never did and i was told that i was
taken off the list
you know i can only guess at this point
i think it went
higher than the chair i think that it
was
andrew cuomo for his administration
that decided that they didn't want my
voice to be heard
and she's exactly right about that i
mean obviously the media are fully
invested in the cover-up of
andrew cuomo's garbage governance and
andrew cuomo was fully invested in that
cover-up as well i mean imagine if ron
desantis were fully
full-on hiding thousands of deaths in
nursing homes so he could pretend they
protected the nursing homes
like full-on hiding it and everybody
knows it and then the media were like
like the ap reported it weeks late we've
been talking by the way i mentioned this
on the show like a full month ago
probably six weeks ago on the show i
mentioned the fact that new york was not
counting
as nursing home deaf people who died
outside the nursing home but got coveted
inside a nursing home
okay meanwhile speaking of the media
doing heavy lifting on behalf of the
democrats
so democrats continue to prevent any
sort of deal from being cut to provide
some form of relief to the american
people in the middle of the middle of a
covan pandemic
where governments across the country
have basically been shutting down people
from working
by the way worth noting that when we
talk about the differential in how
states have treated this thing
there has been a pretty widespread
differential on unemployment rate by
states in the united states
and it's pretty obvious that it has to
do with the
treatment of covet some in tennessee
which
really didn't shut down fully tennessee
their unemployment rate is like 4.6
percent right now
that was the last i saw yesterday what
you are seeing is
unemployment rates by states it is
fairly obvious which states
are are seeing massive
increases in unemployment and it's all
the ones that decided to do the
full-scale lockdowns full scale
lockdowns like i'm looking at the stats
right now this is from the us
u.s bureau of labor statistics sorry as
kentucky kentucky's june 2020 right so
kentucky didn't shut down
kentucky didn't shut down instead they
just did the social distancing and the
mass morning stuff
kentucky their june 2020 unemployment
rate is 4.3 percent
utah didn't shut down 5.1 percent idaho
didn't shut down 5.6 percent north
dakota didn't shut down
6.1 percent maine didn't shut down six
point six percent oklahoma nebraska
montana south dakota none of them shut
down
six point six six point seven seven
point one seven point two okay now
let's look at the states that handle
this the absolute worst okay let's look
at the states like
massachusetts new jersey new york
california
the unemployment rate in massachusetts
is 17.4 percent in new jersey it is 16.6
percent
in new york it is 15.7 percent in
california it is 14.9 percent
in michigan it is 14.6 percent in
illinois it's 14.6 percent in hawaii
it's 13.9 percent in other words
the harsh lockdowns which did not
prevent death and they didn't
they may have delayed it a little while
but did not prevent death that has some
pretty significant economic consequences
but we're all supposed to pretend that
lockdowns were the solution here
it's it's pretty incredible the media
narrative here is pretty incredible so
meanwhile
while republicans try to actually push
out some sort of relief bill for people
who are unable to work thanks to the
government crackdowns
democrats continue to put out their
trillions and trillions of dollars in
unnecessary spending so mitch mcconnell
pointed out the senator from kentucky
he pointed out that democrats are now
pushing bills that would incentivize
people to stay home
according to a variety of studies the
democrat bill would basically pay four
out of five americans more not to work
than to work if it were continued
through the end
of 2020. here's mitch mcconnell
it disincentifies rehiring
and reopening to pay people more to stay
home
plenty of democrats said they saw the
point
and were happy to negotiate on this the
senior senator from maryland said quote
we certainly understand we don't want to
have a higher benefit
than what someone can make working oh no
but the speaker and the democratic
leader overrule
them no deal no deal
unless we pay people more to stay home
meanwhile chuck schumer is is
getting the run of the media for
suggesting that mcconnell is being
political
so you could like last week senator rob
portman suggested why don't we just
extend unemployment by like a week
like a week let's just keep doing what
we've done for like a month could we do
that democrats are saying no hiroshima
is saying oh it's
mitch mcconnell being political its
schools its businesses its renters its
homeowners its essential workers its
post office its elections
state local governments our health care
system
leader mcconnell doesn't seem to
understand this
he sees everything through a political
lens
but we democrats are looking at the real
needs of people
and they're large and that is why we
called for a large bill
because it was needed it was needed to
hold up a relief package that pretty
much everybody agreed on
that was spending a trillion dollars a
trillion dollars
don't worry the media will provide that
literally their entire job is just to
provide cover for democrats like
chuck schumer and and andrew cuomo it's
pretty incredible alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we will see
you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is b shep in the
hizzy
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clinton